you are on the cover of Entertainment
Weekly that yes I think that you have to
show me where the boobs are oh really
yes that was my idea now this was your
idea to be you're lying here it looks
like virtua completely naked yeah
covered in bought empty bottles of booze
yes yeah this was yeah I mean I am a
drinker did you did you drink any of the
bottles of booze while you were there
yeah but they're mini bottles so like
drinking all of those that's like one
drink
all right there appears to be about
10,000 here so no I think you're wrong
never Jake one or two but I wanted to be
naked because I'm I'm aging like the
president so I was like let's show
everybody
not like our prep a president ever I
always like age fast it's kind of
getting a lot of pressure you know yeah
why though I could do it I'm just
kidding
I uh but I was like let's capture this
before like things are on the floor so
let's go well I think you look very sexy
okay
[Applause]
oh so hard you know girls like I don't
know girls it has no ideas she's sexy we
have a lot of women come here and do
that they wear skirts like them they're
just turning and it's fascinating up
itself in the article you talk about
they actually talked to your friends and
they're all saying what is it that makes
Amy so funny what did you glean from
that I mean what do you think made you
honey was it I've went something when
you were a child yeah it's like a it's a
memory I just had actually my brother
who lives in Chicago minded me that my
two front teeth didn't fall out until I
was in fifth grade and this is cool cuz
then at the same time I got my period
so yeah so I was just like this
jack-o'-lantern with tits while I was
just
and my mom I'd one of those really cool
moms I told you like you don't have to
shave above the knee so I just like was
a werewolf
Christopher Robin pants hair horrible
yeah Christopher Robin pants of hair of
hair oh my god I was like I better get
some charisma yeah yeah yeah we're all
forced into comedy for different reasons
never good it's never good never good
now you are hosting the 2015 MTV Movie
Awards that is this weekend Sunday
Sunday and I hosted that thing last year
and it is cool it is different than all
of the other award shows yeah yeah they
asked me they said they wanted to like
make it funny again yeah and
[Applause]
um but yeah any advice well no I forgot
is what I thought was different about it
is you go out you know other award shows
you come out and it's very you know
people in tuxes are right then that show
you come out and there's all this sugar
energy and remember looking out in the
audience and the first person and this
is not making this up sitting in the
audience that I made eye contact with it
was grumpy cat grumpy cat was on a
pillow with a handler and and I was
performing for a cat and it really did
feel like the fall of the Roman Empire
like this cat needs to be amused bring
the clown out dancing around for a real
cat yeah yeah make sure you're not
performing for a cat no you're gonna
rock it though you're gonna have Frank
yeah cool it's easy for me to say that
huh I know you don't know I don't know
you're gonna be great yeah I don't know
I am I think there's something wrong
with me that I'm not nervous about it
maybe I'll be nervous that night but uh
yeah might one of the my friends Chelsea
Brady said in that article that she I
don't care what people think to a
clinical degree yeah and yeah kind of an
insult right my friend I think yeah
she's sort of pretty much saying you
have a mental illness yeah it's just
hurtful
ah but uh but no I'm I'm feeling good
about I'm pretty excited
you